[Music]
okay Jan I got 17 to 20 to kind of step
back one starts at 16 - the link between
takes care of itself there's been a
change right here I'll go I'd like to
stick with the original version and I've
talked through how it works as as we go
okay okay so 16 to the 22 so I've just
done fifty sixteen double time this in
the same place of 15 this stayed up a
bit higher to give a good start to the
sequence and also it's easier for a take
down this floor so I'm in 16 so the 1722
okay so from 18 on was this fairly soft
strong downwards feeling to the Kartha
so thrusts there so I see them dropping
death it's quite natural to go to 19
here he blocks that okay so now we know
it's stuck he's he takes the initiative
by raising to strike my head okay now I
can he tell the movies hands quite a way
to get out of it if I do a load of
strike I can drop my body below and
leave my hand roughly in the same place
so I can out speeding
20:21 double-time
he then has to defend from their lips to
strike my the following month okay so
why I need to go down from there so from
the block yeah if I just strike to the
knee from standing you can hit me on the
head basically so as he comes up I
strike the knee get out of the range and
hit me it's geometry from here here I
mean I'm easily you can hear me it's
problems with the low strikes low thrust
in general is if you're vulnerable
by doing this drop I actually get a like
a tiny bonus on him he then has to get
out away of that and then it's leaves me
come up here there's something have
problems with this its position you drop
me so you need a lot of weight on this
plate here this knee is off the ground
okay and then as you draw this up
4:22 actually puts more weight than the
lady come up there's no issues about
moving up out of it
ride the LA ugh - you know that's it
wait the front leg heavily a while ago
psycho says he's seniors fancy doing
strike from spammy because he couldn't
do the drop and the strike his knees
were bad he think what the drove
afterwards but the way it's always been
done this just dropped with the strike
it's three makes more sense to do it
that way
21:32
[Music]